the Hillsdale you taught how to think
you're taught how to meet challenges and
they'll exceed them and then wait for
the next challenge that is helping my
entire career that chance to just spend
four years immersed in learning becoming
a better human and the focus on soul and
the body it's it's just it's
irreplaceable I got involved in the
collegian very early and from there the
firm that I want to get into journalism
so I spent the next four years
outside of my tenure in in Washington
with whip you know focus mostly on the
collegian collegians sort of became the
focal point of debate about what
Hillsdale was going to be those
relationships that were forged have been
lifelong relationships we had people who
were just amazingly great at their
fields they were brilliant they were
world renowned in the political science
in history and yet they wanted to teach
they wanted to be with us they wanted to
make us better I had no clue where I was
gonna go I just wanted to go out and
cover stories and write and then got
into editing and I started at the bottom
from there kind of got an opportunity
after opportunity just kind of
serendipity that led to my job at the AP
where I was deputy business editor and
then business editor they they cover the
world there's nothing like being at the
AP when a a big story breaks and then
out of the blue I get a phone call I met
the deltas chief executive officer then
and the president and the president's
now the CEO he said listen Kevin you're
a great storyteller and we need to
improve you know
storytelling at Delta but most
importantly your values for the hours
and the Delta values are the most
important thing and how we treat people
two years in it is the key reason why
Delta is considered the best airline in
the world did I ever think I'd be here
no but I never thought I really was
anywhere my career is just sort of gone
from place to place and I've been
blessed
Gregor sent me an email and I open it up
as in congratulations so you're gonna be
awarded a I literally laughed because I
this the last thing I ever thought I'm
undeserving of the award I've had a good
career I'm just thrilled and I'm totally
honored to get this a recognition it's
it's means a ton to me I can't sit here
and say specifically oh I know I'm where
I am because of Hillsdale but I am
you